or the title of his book the
dictatorship of woke capital using the
search box at the top of the page
hi everyone i'm heather moran and i'm
the ceo here at sixth and i on behalf of
our entire team thank you for being here
with us tonight i also want to thank the
jcc of san francisco for being our
promotional partner and give a warm
welcome to any of our viewers from the
bay area
this evening we are so honored to
welcome malcolm gladwell back to sixth
and i in celebration of his new release
the bomber mafia we had the pleasure of
hosting malcolm back in 2013 for his new
york times bestselling book david and
goliath so this is a much anticipated
return to our now virtual stage
considered by many as one of the world's
top thinkers malcolm gladwell's work
uncovers truth's hidden and strange data
and cuts through conventional wisdom to
glean new ways of understanding of how
the world works
malcolm is the new york times
best-selling author of six books and the
co-founder of pushkin industries the
audio content company that produces his
award-winning podcast revisionist
history he's been a staff writer at the
new yorker since 1996 and previously
covered business and science for the
washington post for nearly a decade
in the bomber mafia malcolm delves deep
into questions of how technology and
best intentions collide in the heat of
war
building on his exploration of these
themes in the most recent season of his
podcast he weaves together the stories
of a dutch genius and his homemade
computer a band of brothers in central
alabama a british psychopath
and pyromaniacal chemists at harvard
to examine one of the greatest moral
challenge
challenges in modern american history
malcolm is in conversation this evening
with one of our favorite guests dan pink
dan is the author of six books about
business and human behavior including
the number one new york times bestseller
is drive and to sell is human we are
lucky to call him a great friend to
sixth and i and we can't wait to host
him for the release of his upcoming book
about regret
later in the program we'll take some of
your questions you can submit them using
the q a button at the bottom of your
zoom window
we're also including a link to purchase
additional copies of the bomber mafia in
the chat box and each of those comes
with a signed book plate
thanks again for joining us and please
help me welcome malcolm gladwell and dan
pink into your homes
hello hi everybody hey malcolm good to
see you good to see you
um
first let me start by thanking six and i
what a great part of washington dc my
adopted hometown malcolm's former
stomping grounds it is such a vital part
of the life of ideas in this city i
cannot wait till we're able to do stuff
back in person
however the good news about doing things
virtually is that we have people around
the country if not around the world who
can taste some of the magic of six and i
and so i see in the chat we've got
people from texas we've got people from
new mexico we got people from california
here for this conversation with
malcolm gladwell so malcolm we're here
to talk about this book here the bomber
mafia
seriously
this is a great read
i so enjoyed reading this book i mean
and i have to say it's not some books
you read and it's like okay yeah i
learned something and i had a it's kind
of but this is just a freaking great
read i really really enjoyed it um but
it didn't start out to be read it
started out to be heard so tell us about
the you sort of did a reverse commute
usually books go from print to audio
you went from audio to print tell us
about that
well i got interested in this topic when
i was doing
my last season of revisionist history
and
i realized you know i ever since doing
my podcast i've become very interested
in
audio storytelling
and aware of
the circumstances under which that's a
better way to tell a story
and it struck me from the beginning of
this one that this was the right way to
tell the story or at least a good way to
tell the story
for a number of reasons one is that
there's just so much extraordinary tape
from
the second world war so you know i this
is a story about these two figures
heywood hansel and curtis lemay and how
they
their their visions collided
over the skies of japan in 1945
you know you can
you got to hear lemay who understand who
lemay is i mean
and
you got to hear
what a bombing attack sounded like and
you got to hear
the voices of the victims of these
bombing attacks i mean it was there was
so much that was it struck me that was
emotionally powerful
about telling the story in audio form
that that's where i began
and i wrote the audio book and then i
realized it also
works beautifully as a
as a book as a print book but
um i think for too long in storytellers
have neglected the
audio form of their stories and have
just
been to i think have focused unduly on
the on the printed page
well well certainly i mean the beginning
of stories in human civilization they
were spoken um because we didn't we
didn't have writing we didn't have a way
to memorialize those we didn't have a
way to memorialize those spoken words
into text and then transmit them to
people now we have sort of a back to the
future where we're able to transmit
stories in a powerful way but in the
old-fashioned way are do you this is a
strange question
are these different stories
in
print
versus in audio
well i certainly the fact that i've now
done six seasons of a podcast
has altered the way i write
so
before i started doing my podcast i
would never have written this kind of
story in the way that i wrote this story
so even if you're reading the printed
form
the way i'm writing is yeah
heavily informed by
the fact i've spent six years now doing
a podcast i mean it's
it's supposed to feel conversational and
immediate in that way
and i
the way that i approach
character and plot and detail and it's
just so much influenced by
you know it's hard to describe when you
do a podcast episode
i i thought at the beginning when i
started six years ago i thought it was
just simply
new yorker pieces
done in sound that's what i thought it
was it's just it is so not bad yeah a
completely different animal and you know
i've had a team of pushkin
um
my editor julia barton for example or
my my first producer mia labelle who've
kind of taken me by the hand and taught
me
how to tell a story in sound and i'm a
different
writer now than i was six years ago
yeah it's interesting because i came to
the book the print book having not heard
any of the podcast episodes
and and it did the writing did feel
different uh you know think shorter
sentences one word sentences
transitions that seemed a little
punchier so but i thought it worked i
thought it worked extremely i thought it
worked extremely well do you have a
preference do you want people to
read the audio or do you want them
listen to the audio or read the or read
the print book well both yeah but do i
have a preference yeah
they can go to bombermafia.com and
download the audiobook or they can buy
the print book i think it depends
a lot of it depends on what your what
your
um
preference is yeah you know if there are
kids who never read books then they but
they consume huge numbers of books
um of audiobooks so for that person get
the audiobook there are other people my
mom's not going to listen to an
audiobook i mean she wants to read
my mom should read the book i mean i i
think this is i think we should properly
dan as writers
we ought to become agnostic as to what
form
readers use to consume our work we need
to provide them with a series of options
and i think we're making mistakes if we
say i'm just someone who does audiobooks
or i'm just someone who does print books
right right right um and you've
certainly elevated the i've listened to
part of the audiobook you've elevated
the form of the audiobook it's much more
than simply one person
reading a text into a microphone and
then having that transmitted but let's
so let's let's let's move to the story
itself it's a fascinating fascinating
story
really really well structured it's
structured in sort of in sort of pairs
the first part of the book talks about
the the the dream the second part about
the temptation and at the center of
these books are two technologies that
are that are in some ways characters in
the book um
tell us about those two technologies um
and then we'll get to the the
personalities that you mentioned yeah
the two technologies are
the first is i think called the norton
bomb site which was
you know the three major
uh technological feats of the second
world war the american effort the first
was the most expensive and most the
hardest was of course the manhattan
project right the second biggest project
was the b-29 bomber
but the third
was this little analog computer called
the norton bomb site a 55 pound
mechanical device a bunch of
of knobs and
buttons and gyroscopes and pulleys and
that was intended to solve a problem
that had bedeviled
bombers since the
first bombs were dropped from airplanes
which is how do you make sure that bombs
lands where it's supposed to land it's
an insanely difficult physics problem
right you know you're in a plane going
200 miles an hour and you're trying to
you're six miles up in the air and the
wind's blowing at 75 miles an hour and
the temperature is going to change 100
degrees from the point that you
you drop the bomb to where it lands on
the ground and the thing
you know the earth is
moving on its axis as the bomb is
dropping and you know the there may be
cloud cover and there may be people
attacking you and shooting bullets at
you i mean
the idea that you could drop a bomb
accurately under those conditions is
ludicrous
so along comes this eccentric dutch
inventor named carl norton who goes to
the us military
uh just before the outbreak of the
second world war and he says i've solved
the civic problem this is the physics
problem give me a couple hundred million
dollars
and i will produce for you
thousands and thousands of thousands of
these contraptions
that allow you to mechanically enter all
of the variables that will affect the
flight of a bomb and land a bomb with
perfect accuracy where you want to land
it and
my story is about the group of people
who fall in love with the potential of
that analog computer
and who realize oh wait a minute that
could allow us to reinvent war
the other technology that's at the heart
of this book is stephan
napalm we associate it with the vietnam
war
was not invented for vietnam it was
invented
to defeat japan
because what japan really what we
realized japan was in the 1930s is we
were contemplating a conflict with them
so japan was a country made up of the
biggest
tinder boxes in the world of cities
constructed out of
wooden
and tar paper houses
standing side by side on narrow streets
if you put a match in the middle of it
the whole thing will go up in frames
and so the army
tasked
a group of chemists at harvard
university to produce the world's
greatest incendiary weapon and they do
that and it's called
and napalm is the opposite idea you're
not trying to drop a bomb with precision
you're trying to drop a bomb and just
burn the whole thing down
and those two ideas
are championed by different people
within the air corps at the beginning of
the second world war exactly and one of
them is a and and the people who are
championing that that the
the bomb site the the the people who
became what you call the bomber mafia
were actually in there in a way
idealistic uh about
fighting about about about fighting wars
and it's embodied in this fellow uh
haywood hansel tell us about him
heywood hansel is i mean he's such an
american character he's a
gatsby novel he a guy
sorry a gatsby novel um
you know what i'm saying uh uh
fitzgerald now harold novel yes yeah he
is he's a kind of
fifth generation southern military
families you know great grandfather was
a general in the confederate army he's
this
romantic
poetry writing broadway tune singing
uh his favorite novel is don quixote
because he
identifies with
the gallant knight tilting at windmills
he he's my favorite story is he's gone
so much from his home life that he one
time he comes home and is
having dinner with his wife and he hears
a sound and he said what's that his wife
says that's your son
baby was crying in the other room um
he he is the champion of this device
bomb site and he the great believer in
this vision that a group of pilots had
uh all based in alabama in the 30s the
northern bomb site would allow them to
reinvent war that you would no longer
have to kill
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
civilians in the course of any kind of
major conflict you could use the bomb
site just to bomb exactly those crucial
targets you needed to bomb to overwhelm
your enemy
just take out the power plant and the
aqueducts and the bridges don't worry
about
do you have to destroy the whole city
anymore just take out the militarily
significant targets
um
and he is
he carries that vision into the second
world war and convinces the military
brass the top military brass
of the
both the moral and strategic correctness
of this vision
and he takes it through europe all the
way to japan
to the war against japan in
the winter of 1944.
um so he's like the
he's the kind of leader of this group
that called themselves the bomber mafia
with this very i i read it as this very
idealistic approach that we can that
wars are necessary they're a way to i
mean the conventional view is there wars
are ways to force a country's political
leaders into changing their behavior
changing you know submitting uh but but
we could do it in a very precise way and
this was tell us about this was a
radical idea this was not just like oh
we have a slightly different strategy
here this was
almost unheard of and it was
like many unheard of ideas it was cooked
up in this kind of strange
unusual place in alabama um but but give
us a sense of how unusual that was and
what at least what the prevailing view
of bombing was
so then
think about planes are brand
new you know they're and they were used
in the first world war but if
conventional military thinking was that
they were toys they were
they were an afterthought they they
weren't significant at all to the
outcome of a war
alanka in the bomber mafia and said
they're not toys they are in fact the
most important element in any modern
conflict and they said we think that a
modern bomber
that can fly really high and really fast
will be unstoppable and if it's equipped
with the norton bomb site it can drop
bombs with unerring accuracy and destroy
everything we need to destroy in enemy
territory and as a result and this was a
crucial thing and as a result every
other element of
the modern military will be made
obsolete we won't need the navy we won't
need the marines we won't need tanks
troops artillery
infantry you name it
all gone right so you've got a band of
men in their 20s and 30s in montgomery
alabama
in 1935
who are
pursuing and promoting an absolutely
heretical idea that
that
our conventional understanding of
military which goes back thousands of
years they were saying that it's all
it's over it's obsolete and it's it's
and it's and it's actually what's
fascinating to me i didn't know this
what's what's doubly heretical about it
is that at the time
the pilots the air force is not a
separate branch of the military
that
it was basically the army had a few
planes essentially
yeah these guys were preaching this
this notion this heretical notion from
within the army they were they were
junior officers who were saying to all
the brass back in virginia and
washington dc
you guys are on the wrong side of
history i mean there was a joke they
were all all of maxwell air force base
in montgomery it was a joke that would
go around in those days that if the army
back at in washington knew what was
happening in montgomery we would all be
in jail
that's how that's how radical what they
were doing really was yeah and and and
the the idea was is that you you could
just the the strategic idea was that you
could just kind of bomb indiscriminately
that you could fly at night it didn't
matter whether you flew at night or
during the day you just wanted to drop a
lot of bombs in a lot of places and
wreak as much havoc as you possibly can
it was the opposite of that they were
talking about very narrow targeted
bombing uh the prevailing view though
was
area bombing or
um
what uh called
strange name morale
morale bombing yeah yeah no that the
idea they were
confronting was the idea which
um was held by most conventional
military thinkers at the time which was
the usefulness of a bomber was in
reducing your enemy's cities to rubble
yeah that the point of bombing was to go
in bomb everything
kill lots and lots of civilians and so
demoralize your enemy that he will give
up that's what people thought bombing
was for and the bomber mafia looked at
that strategy with
not
contempt and derision doesn't even begin
to capture it
with a kind of moral horror
they thought it was obscene
right they thought why would you how
could any morally awake human being
participate in a military strategy that
was based
on the destruction of civilian innocent
civilian
life now embodying that in some ways
embodying this other view of how to wage
war was our second character you
mentioned briefly
also striding from
central casting
curtis lemay
tell us about him curtis lemay is the
antithesis in every way of favorite
hansel he is
this child of poverty and grew up in the
streets of columbus
as did i as a matter of fact
my hometown here
i don't want to call me hero but like
all roads lead to central ohio
that's right i did not know that dan
that you've risen to my estimation
he
uh lemay is
looks like a he's got a massive square
head
he's got a huge chest
he is
a man of to say he's a man of few words
is an overstatement he's got a cigar in
his mouth at all times he speaks in this
kind of blunt
guttural kind of growl
he is ruthless unsentimental
bloodthirsty
without conscience
he thinks the way to fight a war is to
be as brutal and unrelenting
as possible in order to end the war as
quickly as possible he is maybe the
greatest aviation aviation tactician of
the second world war he is the
if you talk to an airman from the second
world war who served in the european
theater
and you asked him
who was the greatest pilot you ever saw
they would say without question courtesy
um
you know i thought the analogy it would
be if you asked a basketball player who
played in the nba in the 90s
who embodied basketball they'd say
michael jordan well
curtis lemay was like michael jordan i
mean he was
that's who he was just this but he was
he was a kind of unrelenting taskmaster
and he was
absolutely
uninterested in any kind of broader
moral discussion about right conduct of
of of a military officer in wartime he's
just like no my job is to kill as many
of the enemy as i can in as short a
possible time
as i can
so you can imagine when he discovers
napalm when he discovers that the us has
cooked up the greatest incendiary in the
history of man
and he discovers that
japan
is a country built of
of tar paper and wood
i mean he's like i'm done that's all i
need to know right i'm off to the races
and what i thought was fascinating also
in that is that when they when napalm
came to be and that you have these you
have a band of brothers uh in in in
central uh alabama and then you have
this band of
semi-insane chemists too who are cooking
up this this this this crazy stuff
um they tested it though
um and they actually
they simulated it in a way we might do
on computers today but they did it in
real life tell us about that because i
found that just fascinating yeah so
there's a famous architect named raymond
who was
an american who went to japan in the
1930s and became to this day he's one of
the most famous western architects um in
japan
and the us military goes to him
um after they've developed napalm and
they said build us in the utah desert in
the testing grounds the uh air force
testing grounds build us an exact
replica of a japanese village
so build japanese houses exactly
as they are in japan
and so he builds this
neighborhood of and they import i mean
dan the extent to which these guys went
to
incredible and precisely replicate down
to the tatami mats yes
you know making them exactly as they are
in in in japan they build this
this replica village in the desert and
they
they they launch an attack on the
village with nepal bring in b-29 bombers
you know and drop all of their napalm
canisters and then note what happens you
know they've got their stop watches and
they've got their cameras and video and
movie cameras and they're taking notes
and they're saying well does it all burn
down how quickly does it burn down how
long does it take for the fire to be
uncontrollable what's left at the end
and they they observe
that napalm is perfectly suited
for reducing japanese cities to ashes
within minutes yeah and i think within
seven minutes the fire is impossible
it's extraordinary yeah and they know
they they know at that point they know
oh this
this is the deadliest weapon we could
possibly use against japanese people
and so as the story goes as the story
unfolds the bomber mafia's vision isn't
working as well in practice as it did in
theory and so they
their aim was as as you say to be able
to drop a bomb into a pickle barrel but
they were
less accurate than that and it wasn't
working all that well and so
in
a scene just brilliant that sort of
previous that starts the book but also
sort of is in the back end of it um
this idealistic cervantes reading
son of the south is replaced by
the barrel chested
ohioan whom some of us might remember
for being george wallace's running mate
when george wallace ran on a third-party
ticket
in 1968.
yeah um so curtis lemay before he became
a vice presidential candidate replaces
hansel
in the pacific tell us what happens
haywood hansel takes his
idealistic vision
uh to the pacific theater after guam is
captured in 1944
america is finally close enough to japan
that they can launch bombing raids on
japan they ask
haywood hansel to
command that operation it takes a whole
fleet of b-29s to go on and they build
you know the biggest airport in the
world actually
and they start launching these raids on
japan and hansel's idea is i'm not gonna
i'm gonna kill japanese civilians i'm
not gonna burn down the whole country
i'm gonna take out their their
the plants they use to manufacture
airplanes i'm going to reduce their
their ability to wage war from the air
to
to rubble and that will render them
defenseless against any kind of american
assault right it is the a strategy that
was straight out of
bomber mafia one on one and this is what
they were dreaming of back in alabama in
the 1930s that you didn't have to attack
everyone anymore you just look at the
most military strategic targets and take
them out he says that's what i'm gonna
do
and he tries it he tries it and tries it
throughout
november and december in early january
of 1944 and 45 he makes one
mission sends one mission after another
from guam to japan and
it's all a failure he can't hit anything
the northern bomb site doesn't do what
it's supposed to do
and he thinks he can finally get it
right he really believes that if he's
given enough time
he can resolve all of the problems he's
facing and
what happens is that washington runs out
of patience
and one day he wakes up and there's a
visitor from washington
and it's his boss guy named general
norstad and norstead he thinks noise is
just coming for a courtesy visit and you
know they sit down and they like
have drinks and hear a cigar and no said
says no no
uh it's over
um
and uh not only is it over but i'm going
to replace you with
your nemesis right that
with a man curtis lemay who represented
who was the
antithesis of everything
heywood hansel represented hansel is
this intellectual who idealist who
thought he could resolve the moral
problem of modern warfare
and he gets sent home
and he's replaced by this
brutal you know
anti-intellectual
uh nuts and bolts
hands-on tactician
who is this who you know who will pursue
the war
uh against japan without any moral
qualms whatsoever and and to be
somewhat fair to lemay
he's a very
he's an incredibly
successful and intelligent military
leader um so so so his the way that he
decided to bomb japan took into account
some of the things that were bedeviling
hansel so for instance
the jet stream
yeah the jet stream one of these weird
things you know the jet stream is a
meteorological condition now well known
which says that there is this powerful
wind
which uh circles the earth
200 200 mile an hour plus winds and it
moves over the course of the year well
it happened to be over japan at the time
that haywood hansel was launching his
precision bombing attacks on japanese
aircraft plants
and
if a wind is blowing at 200 miles an
hour how do you aim a bomb with any
precision you can't
planes are being blown sideways if
you're flying into the wind the plane is
literally not moving
i mean you're flying
or if you're flying
with a tailwind of 200 miles an hour
you're going 400 miles an hour how do
you drop a bomb when you're flying at
400 miles an hour and if you're flying
like i said sideways you're just being
literally blown sideways it was
impossible
for
uh for the strategy of the bar mafia to
work under those conditions so lemay
comes in and says all right
i'm not going to fly it 20 000 feet
where the jet stream is i'm going to fly
low and if i'm going to fly low i'm only
going to fly at night because if i fly
low during the day they're going to pick
me off right all of the japanese
anti-aircraft guns will take me out of
the air if i'm going to fly at night and
i'm going to fly low then i'm not going
to i can't see any of my targets
so i'm going to use napalm
and um i'm looking here after this this
is an aside
it might be my absolute favorite
line in the book
when it comes to the jet stream because
the jet stream is not widely known
and the guy who
essentially discovered it who did a lot
of the research on that
his research was not widely known
because
he published most of it
in esperanto
that to me is the greatest one of the
greatest
nuggets so the guy who the guy who's
who discovered the jet stream also
happened to be sort of an esperanto
zealot and his esperanto zealotry
prevented the rest of the world from
learning about the jet stream quickly
now it's just again the book is full of
like really really delicious details
like that so
lemay is flying out and his people are
flying under the under the under the jet
stream they're flying very very low
they're flying at night
does it work and they ha and they have
canisters of napalm that they're
dropping all over these tightly packed
japanese cities what happens
what happens is they turn tokyo into an
inferno
in a matter of minutes they burn down in
one night 16 square miles of tokyo they
burn to death
40 to 50 000 in the space of six hours
when the planes return back to guam
they have to be fumigated because the
stench of
of human flesh burning human flesh is so
overpowering
um
it's one of the deadliest nights of
warfare in human history yeah
and it's
i mean i go the book
that's the end of the book when i tell a
tale of what happened that night and
it's
i mean it's so i went to japan i went to
there's a little museum devoted to
memories of that night
and it is one of the most
moving experiences i've ever had to
interesting
to be
surrounded by mementos of
this terrible thing that
was done
on that night in march and by the way
lemay wasn't done he then
went on over the summer 1945 to napalm
and burn
to the ground 60 the 66 largest
japanese cities with the exception of
two
hiroshima and nagasaki which he saved
for another kind of terrible bomb
and and here's so so let's get to some
of the
um but strategic and moral discussion
about that but here's what
blew me away
and i actually
read this to
the the scent i can't find it in the
book right here but i read it i i just
telling my my wife and son about this at
dinner last night
in 1964
japan
gave lemay
a medal
what the hell malcolm explain that to me
the japanese i mean you could write
another book on how the
on how the japanese chose to memorialize
what happened december 1945 when their
country was reduced to rabble by
um
tons
of napalm dropped by american bombers um
they chose to that museum i mentioned is
not an official museum it's a
it's uh out of a little house on a side
street it's a museum by
one guy who decided ten years ago that
there should be something
to
remember what happened
um
the japanese were not eager to
to dwell on
the end of
the second world war and normal we by
the way we don't tell the story either
one of the reasons i wanted to write
this book is
it's really hard to find any kind of
mention of the firebombing of
of japanese cities in the summer of 45.
um
[Music]
everybody wanted to move on
and one of the ways the japanese moved
on was
in 1964 when lemay is the chief of staff
of the american air force which by the
way is another
extraordinary fact
at one point in the book i i
i list the five people in the 20th
century
who were responsible for the deaths of
the most civilians
stalin is one mao is two
hitler's three
paul pott is four
curtis may is five wow right um and what
happened to curtis lemay he was promoted
and by 19
and jfk makes him his
chief of staff of the air force he's the
head of the air force at the time of the
vietnam war um
his career so
he was both
appointed head of the air force and
given a medal
the highest medal that can be awarded to
a foreigner by the japanese government i
know he wins these despite being the
fifth most
murderous individual of the 20th century
i mean
it's just like
but but part of the argument if i can
elevate it to an argument is that
what he did actually
spared it's a purely utilitarian
argument that what he did actually
spared other deaths it shortened the
length of the war and therefore saved
other lives
well that's the argument it's made of
course on behalf
yeah um
that i think and i think there's a lot
of truth to that that
in the absence of
certainly in the absence of the atomic
bombs
um
[Music]
uh a a a land invasion of japan by the
united states
and also a land invasion of japan by the
soviet union which of course was poised
you know to attack on the other side of
um
would have been would have resulted in
casualties
even greater than
where it were
um that happened over the summer of 45 i
mean it would have been
probably one of the bloodiest military
campaigns in
modern history so there's no doubt about
that but i do think you can
did lemay really need to burn 66
japanese cities around over the course
of
um
in retrospect you know he went rogue
in the summer of 45. it wasn't like
people in washington were telling him
hit another city and hit another city
and hit another city he was even burning
down
japanese cities after the atomic bombs
he didn't stop
you know they wipe out
hiroshima and
nagasaki and curtis may is still sending
b-29s full of napalm to burn down
japanese cities from guam i mean so
there's a there's a moment when he's
you've kind of feel like he's cursed in
apocalypse now that he's kind of
kind of gone off the deep end a little
bit
yeah
is this it's interesting talking to you
now i i i
uh
when i read the book when i finished the
book i was thinking is this
an anti-war book
well you know it's funny it's
what is it
it's a book about so many different
things yeah um
it kind of is
you know i it's funny i had a i'll
answer this question um elliptically i
had a conversation the other day with
a guy
at rand grand corporation who had led a
war game
um which was intended to answer the
question of what would happen if north
korea became a failed state
so they modeled it
what would happen if north korea was a
failed state and we had to secure all of
the nuclear weapons currently held by
earth
so they
they gave it out in the most
sophisticated way imaginable
and the answer is
a nightmare what happens is a nightmare
of a
kind that we haven't seen in 75 years in
this country
i mean
he said it would make this guy was
talking to so it kind of makes iran and
afghanistan
combined look like a walking
right and i said so
what do you what's the take-home lesson
from this war game and he said well it's
supposed to be a reminder to people
in north korea and people in washington
that you should do absolutely everything
in your power
to avoid this eventuality
you do not want this to happen that was
his point right that's the reason we do
this it's just a mess
and i kind of feel like
we always need to be reminded of that
fact
you know i thought that the
you know the
i continue to believe the bush
administration was
was the most morally
i think bush was way worse than
i mean i don't know
i think it was way worse than trump on
every level
largely because of
his the cavalier way those guys went to
war
i mean they totally forgot that lesson
you know they need to be reminded look
you don't go to war at the drop of a hat
because you have a bee in your bonnet
it's always
a brutal nasty
business that goes on way longer than
you think and forces you into moral
decisions that you don't want to make
right
and those guys need to be reminded of
that well so what is this book this book
maybe is one of
a thousand books
that people should read to remind
themselves that you don't want to go
down this path if you can at all
possible avoid it
um
on that point i'll offer another book
once you buy both the audio and the
print edition of the bomber mafia
available today
uh if you're interested in what malcolm
was talking about i encourage you to
look at a book called um i think it's
called to start a war by robert draper
which is kind of a tick-tock about how
the bush administration went to war and
one of the things that's interesting
about that book is actually how
it was actually fueled by a lot of
idealism blind stupidity stupid idealism
but some degree of idealism and that
makes me wonder about war like is it all
is
you know it
like is war
pointless is war
inevitable
it's neither pointless nor inevitable i
mean i think there are times when you
i mean we had to go to war against the
germans in the second one but we didn't
have a choice right
and against the japanese
yeah we blew our opportunity to stop
hitler so what what what choice do we
have but to go to war um
uh and there are there are occasions
when i think we have no choice but i do
think that
we need to try a lot harder to prevent
them
and
we need to perhaps weigh the
the cons a little more carefully before
we plunge into some of these
like i was hearing i was listening to uh
one of the podcasts that actually that
we make at pushkin industries uh tim
harford's podcast and he had an episode
on
it was talking about the british
involvement in afghanistan in the 19th
century
and it's like
it's absurd
i mean
it's this great this crazy notion the
british had that oh we can just send
some troops into afghanistan and
subdue them and
rule the show and of course that you
know everyone who's ever gone into
afghanistan has just has discovered
that's not possible but like
the amount of thought that they were
warned not to do it you know and the
amount of thought that seems to have
gone into
the decision to go to war against
afghanistan
um
in the highest ranks of the the british
military at the time just seems like
they were as cavalier as the
bush administration was before iraq it's
just like
there's like there's a kind of sense i
think sometimes that
it's going to be all very
straightforward
you know
and it just never is straightforward
right now we have so let's go up let's
go to i know you spent in the book you
talk about some encounters you have with
um
members of today's military some
meetings and things you have with them
and one of the things i like about this
book is that there is
at least what i'm reading is is is a
great deal of respect for people who
serve in the military um and i think
that many of us who even if we have
feelings about war or about certain wars
that are critical
those of us who have encounters with
people who are the individuals who are
serving there are there some really
extraordinary individuals devoted to
service incredibly disciplined just
really a great group of just an
incredible group of human beings and now
what we have in bombing is something
that is almost like the bomber mafia
part two
which is
we don't have bomb sites
we have
computers here like the one in front of
me where i can send a bomb
into
a pickle barrel
in a room
somewhere in
basra
that's the dream
what's
what are the unforeseen consequences and
what might be the temptation
with those tools of warfare now
at one point when i was reporting this
book i had
dinner with the chief of staff of the
air force um
the former chief staff the the
um
uh
general golfing and um
uh he
was sitting in his backyard with a bunch
of his
senior
uh leadership in the air force
and uh
he was describing to me the different
generations of
of effectiveness of precision bombing
you know it's like
if somebody wanted to take us all out
here you know my backyard in the second
world war they would have had to bomb
the whole base
to get me and then in vietnam you'd have
taken out you know
the street and in
you know kosovo you'd have taken out the
house and
now they could just take me out and
everything else yeah
left standing um
and
on the one hand that allows you to
fight wars without
killing lots of innocent people but as
as he said he made the obvious point
he's like it makes war the decision to
go to war really easy
um
and maybe too easy and i think that
keeps him up at night i mean
i'm with you dan this book was
in the course of doing this book i grew
to have enormous respect
for the military leadership in this
country um somebody described this my
book
i wonder i was reading some reviews like
malcolm has written a
uh uh you know
has
his book is about his love affair with
the air force and i was like
is that true that is absolutely true i
fell in love with the air force now i
was always partial to the air force to
be honest but yeah i came away from this
in all of these people and they are not
these guys are not
insensitive to the
problems caused by no decision warfare
they are all too aware and they work
really really hard to make sure we don't
fall into that trap you know but
unfortunately not unfortunately but it
is a condition of the way the system
works in this country that
military decisions are made by
political leadership
why not by
on the advice and which consultation
with military guys but
right um which is in some ways
well we can another it's another book
it's a it's for our graduate seminar in
political theory it's like without the
trade-off of that is that we don't have
political decisions made by military
people um which is something we
obviously don't want okay so we got lots
of questions coming in um they are
they're they're coming in like
like like bombs into a pickle barrel
here on my um
uh
phone here so i'm that's i'm not looking
on instagram i'm looking at the
questions that are coming in um let's
see here
okay this is fascinating uh michael asks
can you
talk more
about
this is a great question can you talk
more about the service academy chapels
which you mentioned in the book
why do you think the ideological
differences between the branches show up
so significantly in their places of
worship so you're gonna have to give us
a little background on that obviously
but it's a great question yeah so this i
got this out of a this insanely
brilliant book and and forgive me
because i have
forgotten the name of the book and the
author and i
a thousand apologies
uh but a political scientist who worked
at the rank corporation in the 70s wrote
this incredible book called
uh the masks of war
and it was all about the differences in
culture between the various branches of
the american military the army the navy
and the air force and
he makes this offhand point
in the book which i thought was so
genius
he was like if you want to understand
the differences between the three three
services
look at their chapels
at their academies and i you know i live
in the hudson valley and i take the
train down and i see west point and the
west point chapel is
this gothic
gray granite monstrosity that looks like
it would survive
a nuclear direct nuclear blast and it
looks like it was built in
the 18th century and it looks like
it represents this guy argued um
everything the army stands for tradition
strength connection with the land you
know on and on and on
and then what's the navy chapel the navy
chapel at the at indianapolis is it
looks like something out of italy it's
this ornate
grand
brass and marble and
a huge you know bozar dome and it's like
it represents everything that's the navy
the navy has this this grandiose
international
vision
they go all around the world they're the
most secure branch you know
nobody competes with them no one can
touch them they have these vast ship you
know it's like
that's very navy this kind of like that
you you you enter into this you know
someone has rubbed the brass on the
railings of the church every morning
before you know every sunday morning
before services that's navy right
what's the air force chapel well
i didn't want to ruin it i would
encourage everyone listen when we're
done go on your phone and google
air force academy chapel that's all i'm
saying
just google it and you will see exactly
what he's talking about as someone who
did that i want to second that motion
uh i sort of wish the photographs were
of these were in here because it's such
a powerful
visual display of the differences among
the same so why does
why do what why do the chapels
why is it what is this
so michael wants to know why do you
think the why do you think the
ideological difference is what he's
calling michael's calling ideological
differences show up there
because
i think
chapels in the traditional understanding
of
the the
the role of the chapel plays in a
service academy
it is
it is the place of
where your values are represented right
what you stand for
it's it's it's holy ground it's
you know in the same way that
if you look at different kinds of
churches that different denominations
have they also represent something about
the culture of those
of those churches um you know i i grew
up among mennonites in southwestern
ontario who are pacifists and
who eschew material possessions and who
are the most non-hierarchical people
what does the mentality church look like
it is looks like a quaker church
just a it's a white wooden box
right and then you drive five miles down
the road and you see the catholic
cathedral with its gothic spirals news
you understand these are very different
ideas about
um how to approach
spirituality well in the same way
i think the people who built those
chapels were thinking about
who they were building the chapel for
interesting
yeah fascinating
tina asks in your writing you seamlessly
balance details on the lives of key
characters with an overarching
contextual discussion so she asked when
you approach a book like this
do the characters spur the idea or does
the contextual pattern lead to
discovering the characters
oh wow uh you're asking me to reflect
you're asking the least introspective
person on the planet to be
um
i don't know i mean i suppose a little
bit of both i mean i think there are
times when
you discover extraordinary characters
you just run with them
you understand and then there's times
when you discover an idea and you try
and hunt for
details and people who bring that idea
to life
um here i
and this one i this book i really did
fall in love with the characters i
thought lemay
i discovered lemay and all i wanted to
do was to construct a narrative around
him yeah um and he would hansel um
they were just so when i went to the
to maxwell air force base and chatted
with historians there what was
fascinating to me is they talked about
lemay and hansel
as if they were still alive that's how
real these guys are i mean
both of them are dead for 30 years but
people who study the second world war
they think of these guys as being
next to them right they think they're
still in conversation with them
yeah yeah
rebecca asks interesting question what
do you think curtis lemay and the bomber
mafia would think of drones
well obama mafia would say that's our
vision made real that's what we were
talking about in 1935 in montgomery
alabama
lemay would say
okay they're great give me a thousand of
them
let's go uh right he said okay
let's do this let's go against japan or
about let's go against china tomorrow
that's what he would say
yeah
um
a couple of uh
i'm gonna save this one uh
are there are there are there other
episodes of revisionist history that
you've considered
expanding
into books and i see in the chat here
that someone
googled
someone googled the air force chapel and
typed into chat omg exclamation point
exclamation point exclamation point
exclamation point which is the
appropriate response to that are there
are other episodes of revisionist
history that you consider expanding into
books or it's not even expanding sort of
like sort of
fashioning into books yeah
oh yeah in fact this season
i'm gonna have an episode which
one episode
devoted to
i've gotten really interested in
policing i'm gonna do one little little
episode for revisions history and then
the hope is to turn it into a
a
a big audio book over the course of the
next year i want to this is a model i
mean i think of religious history
episodes now is
they're really kind of
rehearsal spaces you know for
interesting yeah it's so interesting and
then you can like with this i did a
couple of episodes on
on curtis may last season and just
realized oh this was the beginning of a
this was a a little kernel that i could
blow up into a
a really really really interesting and
powerful book and that's that to me is
what that the exercise of doing the
podcast is all about yeah do you have
other
media companies
approaching you saying we'd like to
option
this episode
to turn it into our own
yeah but
nothing ever comes to mind my
my
my
the thing about hollywood is they have
100 ideas and one thing makes it to the
screen and after a while
when you're young you think you get very
excited when they call you exactly yeah
you get old and jaded and you're like
all right
you know right something actually
happens yeah yeah um
here's a question from carol um
over your right shoulder is poster
of someone you mentioned earlier
what malcolm is the significance of the
mouthpost poster she wants to know
i um
years ago found online i have three i
have chowin lai i have mao
and i have another one who another guy i
don't know i don't know his name i have
three of the sort of murderers roe of
the cultural revolution above my desk um
to remind me to be a good boss
i think
okay so
so there you go so and and what are the
employees of push can think of that when
when the head dude has a a poster of mao
above his desk well you know
also i better not disagree with this
dude
i love doing interviews from my desk
with you know some serious buttoned up
corporate type and then halfway through
the interview you see their eyes
wandering
away from me and towards
the poster above my
above my head and i think i know what
they're thinking they're thinking oh my
goodness is this dude some kind of
maoist and then they start to regret
everything they've said over the last 15
minutes that's always my favorite moment
in any interview uh and are you a mouse
because because you're a canadian which
you all know is a gateway drug to maoism
not about it's not even remotely i just
think it's what you can't see is on my
other wall yeah i have these three
beautiful
uh
paintings done by um my friend the
artist lauren redness of people from the
new york city ballet so i have
ballet people on one wall
and i have murderous
dictators on this one so it's a you have
to see everything in context you've got
a whole dyadic thing going around going
on here you've got like hansel and lemay
and and all that um i want to ask you
one
uh i'm gonna uh ask you some questions
very as we wrap up here
i'm gonna ask you some rapid fire
questions and then i'm gonna ask you a
two final questions okay so rapid fire
questions people like to know this kind
of stuff you have 15 seconds to answer
what are you reading now or what have
you read recently that really
moved you
just picked up the
biography of
robert maxwell very excited to read that
interesting okay um what are you
watching
um or have you watched recently
uh whether it's a play whether it's
something on television whether it's a
film anything that you've watched
recently that you found compelling then
it ran out i mean
the
pandemic went on for so long that i ran
through
all of the kind of you know conventional
tv favorites from tehran to
i went back and watched prisoners of war
i watched
you know succession i watched everything
everybody watched and then about in like
february no just last december
like we hit a wall i i
i i don't know i need to do something
nothing nothing nothing um okay uh uh
call my agent very funny french series
uh what are you listening to what
podcasts are or any audio that are you
listening to that you're finding really
compelling
i mean science friend i mean obviously
every pushkin product but beyond that
uh well we're you know we're on the cusp
of the nba playoffs so um
i'm listening to a lot of bill simmons
right now
and similar basketball themed content
preparing myself for
uh the grand event of the spring which
is
the nba class and who do you have who do
you who what's your prediction east and
west
i don't have one it's a mess this year i
don't think anyone has one who knows
it's the craziest season i remember like
there are 10 teams that could win the
title i i'm a total at a total loss and
that's why it's so exciting this year
i'm psyched that my wizards
actually might make the playoffs even
though we have a losing record deluded i
know they're on a they're on a run but
you know it's all going to end badly it
always ends badly
it it always ends badly but you got a
guy like like russell westbrook who's
six foot three and had 18 rebounds
yesterday and that i'd just like to see
all right um
let me
uh let me ask you a
final question oh okay let me give you a
fi i'm gonna give the audience a final
question
and the final the audience final
question is this
um
which history books
do you think
should be essential reading give us a
couple of books that you think that have
affected you as a writer as a
storyteller as a thinker that you think
others of us would benefit from
oh my goodness what a difficult question
because there's so many i mean
how would i even begin to say depends
what you what kind of history you're
interested in i mean
there are some vietnam books
let's let's let's focus on let's focus
on res how about how about literature
about recent wars vietnam
right
bright shining live by neil sheehan
fantastic
fantastic book what do you think of the
things they carried it's fiction but by
tim o'brien jim o'brien i would
absolutely say that's as good as any
as any um
and obviously you know
you can't go anywhere without reading i
think that um
the best and the brightest is
i've read it like three times really
it's just so it's just fit it's just
fantastic yeah i mean it's just i mean
harvest um
was
extraordinary i mean you can't be a
writer of non-fiction and not worship
the man
but um
that book is just like
it's just one for the ages they will be
reading that book a hundred years from
now
i will i can't say the same with my
books well yeah i'm not i'm not so sure
i'm not so sure um um i think that you
know if they're you know there are very
few writers especially i mean no
american society doesn't care about
writers generally yeah um
and especially nonfiction writers and so
halberstam is
a name that we know even
um after his death his tragic death um
he had a place in the life of ideas a
place in our conversation um and i think
all of us would agree that you are like
that as well that what you come out with
is important that it gets people talking
about that it gets
dads to bring books to
the dining room table and say did you
know
uh so
we thank you for your
great country thank you for your your
great contributions uh we thank you for
this terrific book uh i hope everybody
gets a copy of it um and thank you to
sixth and i for hosting us if you want a
last word it's yours malcolm well i'm
just going to say you'd be very nice to
me but i should i would be i should i
would i need to point out that in my fan
my brother
um i don't think he's read any of my
books but he's read all of your books
so he whenever you talk he reads almost
nothing but he reads everything by dan
pink well
so we know so again another one of many
things we've learned here at six and i
is who is the really who is the smarter
gladwell brother
yeah and he will talk about you
in a way that just makes me so
profoundly jealous people talk about you
like you are this kind of like and you
are
you know a kind of the intellectual of
his but he literally that's he he does
not read anything except dan pick books
well that is a colossal and tragic life
mistake um i encourage everybody here to
pick up a copy of the bomber mafia
whether it's in print or on audio it's
just honestly folks it's fabulous
storytelling it'll make you think um and
it's very entertaining thank you malcolm
thanks six and i heather back to you
thank you both so much i i have to say
i'm a little bummed that i don't know
what to do with my bracket i thought
maybe i was gonna get some information
but you know you just can't get it all
um but i want to thank you so much thank
you to malcolm gladwell thank you to dan
pink thanks to everyone in the audience
for joining us the link to purchase
books is in the chat box and we're also
emailing everyone the link as well again
those books each come with a signed book
plate and please come back and see us
for more virtual events check out our
calendar at sixth and i dot org and when
the time comes we cannot wait to welcome
you back into our building at sixth and
i so until then take care stay safe and
have a good night
here's a look at some